Democrats in Congress are threatening to
vote against any FBI nominee unless a
special prosecutor is appointed to take
over the Russia investigations and
lawmakers from both parties are asking
President Trump to hand over any
recordings of his conversations with
James Comey if they exist major Garrett
is at the White House major good morning
good morning Robert Gates a former
defense secretary and head of the CIA
said this weekend when a president fires
a top administration official he better
have solid reasons and the ability to
explain them without both motives are
questioned and that's exactly what
congressional Democrats and some others
are doing to President Trump the
president is the CEO of the country he
can hire and fire whoever he wants UN
Ambassador nikki Haley was one of the
few top administration official Sunday
defending President Trump in the face of
claims he asked FBI director James Comey
for his loyalty as a former governor I
can tell you loyalty and Trust is
everything when you're a CEO and so I
can totally understand why he's looking
for loyalty and Trust in an interview
taped Friday the president put loyalty
into a national rather than personal
context did you as a class no no I
didn't but I don't think it would be a
bad question asked I think loyalty to
the country loyalty to the United States
is important congressman Adam Schiff
ranking Democrat on the House
Intelligence Committee condemned talk of
loyalty amid multiple investigations
into Trump campaign ties to Russia
highly unethical at a minimum unethical
if he was in trying to impede the
investigation anyway maybe beyond
unethical after tweeting on Friday that
he might have tapes of his conversations
with Comey the president later dodged
the question that I can't talk about I
won't talk about that if there are tapes
of the president relevant to the Russia
probe Republicans and Democrats say they
should be turned over if in fact there
are such recordings I think those
recordings will be subpoenaed and I
think they'll probably have to turn them
over there may exist private tapes and
we want to make sure those tapes are
preserved because we're going to want to
take a look at it in Congress top
administration officials to say talk of
a White House staff shake-up is real
said one everyone knows it's coming the
question is now
or August things can't keep going the
way they are Shawn spices the press
secretary and communications director
Mike do PR into the microscope and
Charlie we are told the next 48 hours
could be pivotal for both major Garrett
at the White House thanks major